la parole est à Madame Louise Morel pour
le groupe
démocrate merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires et
j'associe à cette question Monsieur
Laurent Croisier député du dou monsieur
le ministre ma question concerne ma
prime renove l'Agence nationale de
l'habitat a annoncé au début du mois de
décembre qu'elle prévoit une baisse de
30 % des forfaits ma prime renve pour
l'installation d'équipement de chauffage
fonctionnant au bois la réduction sera
effective dans quelques semaines à peine
le 1er avril 2024 l'annonce est brutale
elle est sans concertation avec une
filière qui pourtant se structure depuis
des années pour accompagner la
transition énergétique de nos bâtiment
soyons clair cette décision marquera un
coup d'arrêt pour les remplacements des
chaudières au fuel par des chaudières
biomasse plus performantees et neutre en
carbone et cela va également à
l'encontre des objectifs environnment et
de réindustrialisation de notre pays je
dois également préciser que l'inquiétude
est vive pour la pérennité des 450000
emplois directs et indirect de cette
filière filière qui je le rappelle a été
mise à rue d'épreuve l'an dernier lors
de la crise des granulé de bois
rappelons-nous les pelets ont vu leur
prix bondir de manière exponentielle
entraînant perte de confiance et
effondrement des ventes d'équipement de
chauffage au bois en 2023 sur 1 an le
volume des ventes a diminué de 72 12 % à
l'heure où nous devons plus que jamais
être vigilant sur notre consommation
d'énergie ces annonces semblent en
décalage elles inquièteent nos
concitoyens en particulier ceux qui
vivent dans les régions les plus froides
de notre pays aussi Monsieur le Ministre
pouvez-vous nous faire part de
l'intention du gouvernement à l'égard de
cette filière qui participe à sa mesure
à renforcer l'indépendance énergétique
de la France et plus globalement dans
les discussions à venir sur l'énergie
quelles actions entendez-vous prendre
sur la place des granulés de bois dans
notre mix énergétique afin de se
prémunir face à une nouvelle crise à
l'avenir je vous
remercie